[Music] The
president's big announcement Let's dance Backing up and spitting out adversity Get up Koboshi style
road The
sound is out of sync Because the
sound is transmitted later than the light and the people who are obsessed with se It's
okay with thunder I think it's good
I have no experience with smoke, fire, or other effects, so I have to try it, but I want to embrace the
animation
[Applause]
[Music] It's
tareme
g 3
[Music] There
's a real stone statue in the hot water.  There is, even
the casual behavior of everyday life can be stolen and it looks good enough as a Zaku
.
They're two gorgeous people It's
expensive It's a
trick
What kind of pose do you actually pose when you put the sword
in your waist? What happens when you pull it out?
An animator is an actor, and it's not just humans who
act.They act out the movements of cats and dogs.The sea, the storm, the
cars and the planes, they're all my brother Beta's performances.
I want to write a play What I want to make is not anime